Gary this is a very impressive
headquarters I mean we're not even the
headquarters oh it's not there now this
is the second office in New York
headquarters is real fancy fellas were
to listen that's in Hudson Yards on the
west side in New York okay this is our
studio here we have obviously some
office because we're growing so fast
we've run out of room but this office
has about a hundred headquarters has
about 450 oh wow so it gets really crazy
I didn't realize yeah so tell us what an
average day looks like in your life tell
us from morning what would an average
day Gary's life I wake up at 6:00 I work
out till 7 I shower spend 10 15 minutes
with my kids before they go to school
and then I go to my first meeting at
8:00 or 8:30 and usually breakfast
somewhere outside the office usually
I'll get to the office by 9:00 and then
from 9:00 a.m. so basically meanings
from 8:00 a.m. outside the office to
9:00 9:00 in the office till usually six
or seven just every minute book no lunch
no one minute to spare no downtime
meeting after meeting after meeting I
mean you see what's that you've been
happening with this right yeah you know
like it's every second is booked and
then at 7:00 I'll go and do meetings
from 7:00 p.m. to 11:00 p.m. at night
that is the typical day 30% time I'm
traveling going to clients you know only
10% of my life is probably Gary Vee you
know when I speak or do appearances or
do something like this 90% of it is me
being the chief executive officer of
being or X which is the holding company
that owns vaynermedia and pure well the
women's publishing site and so that's
how I navigate you know just meaning
operating operating operating meaning
meaning meaning operating operating
interesting and so what are the let's
talk about business what are the
qualities that you think make for a true
and a successful entrepreneur
important she or he has to love the game
for me a purebred entrepreneur she or he
loves the journey mmm not the stuff you
know one of the things I struggle with
in the current state of entrepreneurship
is a lot of people want the vacations
the watches you know even even the
context is this you guys have such an
incredible imagery I think it's
remarkable
who doesn't want fine things in life
yeah but I think that if you're in the
game just for the fine things in life
for the bottles and the models and the
private planes I think you're gonna lose
and it definitely is not my definition
of an entrepreneur my definition of an
entrepreneur is somebody who can't live
without doing their thing and trying to
create literally suffocated when I was
you know I learned because I've been an
entrepreneur my whole life you work hard
you get a deal you reward yourself buy
yourself a watch with what's your
thoughts on that philosophy I think that
worked for your DNA and I respect that
mm-hmm you know I don't think you get to
judge what somebody does with the fruits
of their labor yeah for me I think that
that's what's amazing about anything
which is there's many different many
different definitions for you you know
go out work your face off win and reward
yourself what something is exactly right
for me the reward is pouring more of the
dollars and energy into the company not
buying stuff for myself it's one in the
same
yeah it's one in the same I don't I
don't judge you know I talk a lot about
like stop posting cash and Lamborghinis
and private jets not because I don't
think one deserves that after they work
hard it's that so many of the people on
Instagram that are posting that are
fronting I never sent I mean they're
like literally driving to a private
plane pad taking the photo and then
driving home there they're full of [ __ ]
and so to me I I think it's amazing if
somebody wants to buy an Armani suit or
a $5,000 pair of belt or a diamond ring
for a hundred thousand
I don't but that doesn't mean that's
right or wrong
what I'm doing with that same hundred
thousand instead of a ring is I'm hiring
two more people because I'm trying to
buy the jewelry company not a piece of
the jewelry all right there no no that's
a great board and your fans and
followers really turn to you for
motivation and inspiration where do you
draw your inspiration and motivation
from who motivates you obviously
everyone there's different levels
animation it's really interesting I've
been thinking about this a lot them it's
crazy when somebody dm's me when you
were like she's a fan it's crazy what
that feels like it's [ __ ] it's amazing
my motivation is in like Elon Musk or
Bill Gates or Warren Buffett it is only
two things my parents and then the
community itself
well you when you say it it's really
true I mean you really are for the
people I mean you love your you love you
know your lovely game on what you're
doing I really do man and what's funny
is like I love talking about it because
I know there's not gonna be another shoe
that drops like I'm not gonna turn dark
you know I was like you know what I
think people struggle with they don't
they forget or don't know that I knew
how to build businesses and made money
before I became somebody people knew so
like kids you know it's very easy for me
to give to my community cuz I'm not
looking for anything from them exactly
that's the other question is to the
outside it seems as though you've had a
lot of success at a young age
talk to us how do you define success for
yourself tell us a little about I have a
really good answer for this one this one
I've known for a long time to me the
ultimate success is doing what you want
to do every day and having nobody have
any impact on that interest and when and
at what age did you start having that
probably you know I had a very item I
had him as a kid because I had a very
successful baseball card business when I
was 13 14 15 so I tasted it early which
is probably why I got addicted to it
yeah when I went into my dad's business
the truth is my dad gave me a ton of
autonomy and that's why I was able to
build him a big business but I didn't
have full control because it was still
my dad's business right though he gave
me unlimited reign when I started
vaynermedia I probably felt it for the
first time because my brother was my
partner but I really was kind of like
the a but even that I had to have
empathy for him it's probably why I like
my personal brand because it's the place
where I have a hundred percent control
you know so that's cool so I would say
somewhere in my mid to late 30s I
started feeling it maybe thirty seven
maybe only five years ago and I think
actually that's probably why so much
good has happened these last five years
cuz I feel like you know super free my
next question is it seems that you have
the magic touch when it comes to
investing early in companies that have
been successful
uber Twitter venmo what do you look for
in early stages of a business to
determine whether or not you would
actually invest your personal money time
two things one do I believe in the
thesis when I invested in venmo in 2009
I thought people would text message each
other to settle payments yeah and back
then people like what cuz everyone was
about PayPal see yeah PayPal wasn't
doing texting no you know yeah to your
point so like it was like you had to
project I thought everybody would have
social media accounts that's not what
people thought in 2007 mm-hmm so I have
to believe in what you're saying and
then number two have to believe in him
or her
the jockey it's all about the jockey for
me where I've lost money is I was right
about the thesis black jet black jet is
a company I invested in right yeah which
is basically jet smarter yeah same
thesis I was right but it didn't become
jet smarter because the jockey didn't
win you're on the wrong side of the
jockey that's right
you know I was chasing euro Bongo euro
Bongo I was right about the thesis the
thesis was tender I had seen the app
Grindr which in the gay male community
was people hooking up and I was like
that's definitely gonna happen with guys
and girls right mm-hmm so every app in
2010 11 12 that kind of looked like it
like people meet each other when they're
in close proximity I was betting okay
but mine didn't become tender so I was
right about the thesis the wrong about
the jockey got it yep one percent when a
lot of people want a lot of people
describe you and what you do presumably
based on your social media they describe
you as a motivational speaker which you
are but you're also an entrepreneur and
yes that's well business person yes how
did that party your persona and career
come about you talked a little about it
but talk to us about that because I mean
all I really said I got is this man I
wrote a book called crush it it was
awfully motivational and it's nuances I
just I you know I didn't realize it to
be frank I've always been a hype man and
excited with my friends and my employees
and in life I started being asked to
speak and the first time I went on stage
it was there I'm like okay and then in
2010/11 it really became a thing like I
was speaking a lot people were saying
that and I didn't want to be it and so
in two thousand twelve to fourteen I
didn't do a lot of Internet content I
wasn't that out there and and I was
really focused on the business and not
looking to build that brand and then 15
I realized that I don't think I'm a
motivational speaker not that there's
anything wrong with that I think I'm an
entrepreneur who happens to be
motivational however in the last two
years I realized the reason I'm really
going all-in is to me it's just strategy
its mental strategy like it's just smart
to be optimistic and to be grateful and
to like the things that people deem to
me as motivational I think it's that I'm
emotionally intelligent
right what are some of the challenges
you've faced or you talked a little
about some of the mistakes you made it
on your investments yep that you made in
your professional career that you
believe you've learned and have become
much better at I was really bad at
firing I was too empathetic I'm really
empathetic it's my superpower and it's
my weakness and so at a macro it's my
superpower but in the micro it's my
weakness I would sit on firing somebody
for a year or two okay because I just
didn't want to fire them I felt bad so I
think that that made me a little bit
less authentic to be frank I feel like I
would sandbag people like it's cool it's
cool it's cool and then just fire them
I'd be upset with them like how didn't
you see you suck at everything but in my
30s I'm glad I went through that at Wine
Library because at vaynermedia have been
much better but even the last three
years I've been better than the first
five years of vaynermedia I need more
radical candor yeah and so being an
empath you are thinking about the other
person you know I always used to say to
my some of my girlfriends and friends
and mom and white layers I was like if I
was a woman I would have loved the bad
boy because I would have loved to try to
like help you know so I think I was I
think that I didn't I think i sat on
decisions too long that were detrimental
to the business out of empathy and what
I did was I empowered the second and
third and fourth tier players at the
expense of the first tier players and I
think I've got a lot better at that in
the last year or two I would think with
the way you run your business you would
expect that to all your employees you
mean accountability just you know from
like I mean you're imprecise to the
point six you know six to seven go to
the gym yeah be with Mike you know
eights know to your point know I hold
myself dramatically more accountable
than I hold others and I think that's
cool and that's what a great leader is
but I don't think I had all the dials
perfect I think I'm very optimistic to
me being an operator from 50 to 60 I
think I'm gonna be really in a great
place with my crescendo of like being
empathetic but also being strategic
about
who's getting compensated in how so I
remember last year you launched your
case with collaboration the Geary be 0 0
1 & 0 0 2 yes I was surprised at how
quickly it sold out I mean I'm a
sneakerhead
yes I mean a lot of people were like
who's gonna buy that you know the a
Swiss is not like you took him beat us
or Nike yeah talked to us about the deal
and I mean obviously K Swiss is a great
brand but it's not against any brain
this I get it I mean you hit yourself up
with a little bit of risk I did but all
upside 100% and so I that's why I did it
it was a nostalgic brand I'm 42 so
k-swiss was flyy in the 80s in the hood
so i knew there was some swag there I
thought my audience would resonate and
so to the credit of the president of of
k-swiss Barney he sought me out we had
breakfast I like the vibe I could see it
wasn't an influencer deal this was a
real collab and we kept working on it we
went there and I was very confident that
I could sell the sneakers and we did and
now that are making a hell of a lot more
for the oo3 and the o4 that are gonna
come out later this year and I'm excited
about it it's been huge for me in
culture you know sneakers as you know
are one of the five 712 kind of pillars
of culture right now at least and being
in that game and surprising the market
was a awfully awfully powerful thing
that to me is because you are a sneaker
had so would have been easier to do a
Nike collaboration or adidas because
obviously it'd have been a lot easier to
sell yeah but I don't think my brand and
I was at a level where they would have
sought me out so it was a real win for
me because one if I did one with adidas
or Nike first of all they would have
gotten the credit not me I think what
the case Swiss situation we both get
credit right I get a lot of credit for
moving it k-swiss gets credit for being
smart to to seek me out and how did you
apply your knowledge into the design of
those shoes to be honest with you the
first one it was very lightweight like I
wanted to be green because of the Jets
you know I wanted them to be things I
would wear
you mean the New York
yes okay and and I wanted to be you know
have a little bit you know has my
signature and it has a you know some my
words and the soul so I was uh the old
three neo four I'm even more involved in
I wanted to be empathetic to the
designers in case Wis I'm not imposing
too much I wanted to learn and watch
them but I still wanted to have my
fingerprint on it now I have my
handprint on this one and eventually
it'll be my hand I mean it's sold out
and now I remember because I follow you
you were showing how it was reselling
for more so I mean in street credibility
yeah I think her heads I mean how
excited was that you know like huge I
mean I believe I couldn't I mean
literally I was sitting there like my
god the 18 year old version of me would
have been the guy that was buying these
yeah and now I had like the only thing I
could say is I never was destined to be
on a sports trading card yeah but like
it was literally the next best thing
so entrepreneur I'm a nine oh we talked
about how you respect your followers put
on an entrepreneur in business people
who are some of the people you look up
to you admire you know I don't look up
to anybody mm-hmm that's just a truth
I admire everybody who's doing it
honestly I mean that if you're making
$100,000 a year sixty three thousand a
buck ninety seven two million and you're
doing it the right way
I admire anybody who's doing that
because entrepreneurship is hard and
lonely right mm-hmm it just is
and so admiration through the I mean
through the means I admire the people at
the lowest levels the people that are
just a case just starting like have a
job and have the ambition to come home
at 7 p.m. and get to grinding like take
that photo try to get the light right
darn it's dark out because I've worked
all day and I got to pay my mortgage or
my debt but I'm still gonna build this
I'm gonna be an influencer I'm gonna
start this t-shirt brand I'm gonna I'm
gonna sell these caps I'm gonna get
brands to pay me for sponsorship on my
basketball mean page I have enormous
admiration for anybody that's trying to
do it because you understand one thing
that people get twisted the second you
say you're about to do something and
build a
company you're out of being an employee
and being a student when you're an
employee in the student you can blame
somebody
babban can blame if the videos don't pop
you can blame me he didn't give us the
resources he didn't give me the right
camera he changed the words you can
blame somebody I can't blame anybody
yeah
if this isn't successful it's your fault
all right it's like they knew you could
say well she wasn't you hired her mm-hmm
like everything that's bad here my fault
all of it that I admire anybody who's
willing to go there because that takes a
level of scrutiny that most people don't
want to deal with in your business the
media side yes most of your competitors
are out pitching and looking for
customers yes one of your customers was
telling me a story holiday for six to
nine months were just trying to reach
out to you it's actually Paragon Auto
yeah they were talking about how they
were just like they were emailing you
they were damning you and they couldn't
get ahold of you and then they called a
friend to a friend and knew a friend I
mean and then obviously they I think
they hired you because they said that
and you obviously are probably charged
get my fee but as a businessman I mean
how excited does that make you feel in
your business because usually in your
business on media they're on the
opposite they're hounding the the
clients for the business when clients
are chasing you for the for your
services it's always fun to be the girl
that everybody wants to take to the
dance